The federal government is trying a
new tactic in its fight to shut down
the DIY Gun Movement and Defense
Distributed, the Austin, Texas based
company founded by the Second and
First Amendment activist and
provocateur Cody Wilson.
But Wilson says he's been preparing
and that this latest attack will
only backfire.
His countermove will continue to
test the limits of how far
the federal government will go in
restricting what Americans do in the
privacy of their own homes.
Founded in 2012, Defense
Distributed sells programable
milling machines that can be used to
make unregistered firearms.
In 2013, the State Department
ordered Wilson to take plans for
his first 3D printed gun, the
Liberator, off his website.
Wilson sued on First Amendment
grounds, which led to a 2018
settlement with the feds.
A media firestorm.
And finally a 2021
Ninth Circuit Court injunction
against states trying to ban sharing
of the files.
Now, the Bureau of Alcohol, Tobacco,
Firearms and Explosives, better
known as the ATF, has drafted a 100
page administrative rule, changing
the definition of a firearm to
encompass weapon parts kits
designed to or which may readily
be assembled, completed, converted
or restored.
If the rules adopted in the coming
weeks, it means the federal
government will require gun part
kits sold on the internet by Defense
Distributed and its competitors
to bear the same serial numbers
as do fully manufactured firearms,
which has the potential to put the
entire industry out of business.
So how is Wilson responding?
Meet the zero percent receiver.
Anything on its way to being a gun
is now considered a gun.
So say I, Uncle Joe, and
this would be smart.
You would think if you're a wine mom
or a lawyer who now controls the
ATF, you know this is Gabby Giffords
grand achievement in kit guns in the
mail. But that's just it.
This was only a reaction to kit guns
in the mail.
Our equipment, our software, 3D
printing and scene similarly can
take raw materials,
blocks of metal, things in their
primordial state and take them from
nothing and turn them into guns.
Wilson and his team tweaked the code
to the latest model of the Ghost
Gunner. It used to be the customers
would purchase partially fabricated
lower receivers using the Ghost
Gunner to finish the job of turning
them into functional gun parts.
Wilson said that Defense Distributed
is the only DIY gun company
pivoting in the face of this new
regulation.
So the real impact of the law will
be to drive out his competitors.
With this rule that Biden is
pursuing, he's giving us,
the nation's premier Ghost Gun
company, I would say a monopoly
of the market.
According to federal law, after a
ghost gunner makes a homemade gun
out of a block of aluminum.
The weapon does not need to be
registered with the federal
government so that the next logical
step that they're going to say,
Well, once you make a homemade
gun, you have to get it registered.
What happens then?
So registration of firearms would
take an act of Congress.
And so, by the way, would most of
the regulations of manufacturing
firearms this should have taken an
act of Congress. Joe Biden knows he
wants to stop ghost guns.
He never had the power.
He never took the power.
He didn't have the congressional
majorities to deliver him a new act
of Congress. He's tried.
He's at hearings looking Blumenthal
and Menendez. These guys, they
really want it. They don't have it.
And you can see how the next year or
two is going to go.
He's going to get even less of that
power, less of that mandate.
So they threw 100 hundred pages at
kit guns in the mail, and they're
going to congratulate themselves.
They're going to say, Hey, we did
it. You know, all they did
was was make us write
the 3D printers, the scenes.
Now we're the only way to do it.
In the wake of the Jan.
6th breach of the U.S.
Capitol, the Department of Homeland
Security has turned its focus to
homegrown domestic terrorism
or the most urgent terrorism
threat the United States faces
today, according to the White House.
In justifying its forthcoming rule,
the ATF cites an uptick in the
number of homemade guns recovered at
crime scenes, and the agency sees
unregistered firearms as a growing
national security threat.
Is there a danger that the DIY gun
movement is going to explode
into terrorism or fuel terrorism?
Look, there's an irony here.
In the state, and its agents don't
necessarily mean it, and they even
enjoy this irony.
But the Homeland Security threat,
I would say from their perspective,
becomes even greater when
you pass these regs because more
people will take the exclusively
private route that we are now
offering.
Wilson says that the regulation
will mean that more DIY gun
smiths are buying blocks of aluminum
instead of gun kits.
The sales of which can be more
easily surveilled by law
enforcement.
Does that bother our national
security strategists and our
anti-white supremacist legions?
No, because they'll just say, "Well,
now a year from now, making a
gun is, of course, the surest sign
that you're some kind of domestic
terrorist or something." So they
enjoy this.
The problem is we enjoy too.
Sorry.
It'll be it'll be dark, right?
People are going to make guns, are
going to choose gun privacy.
They're going to choose ways to to
acquire weapons outside of
government oversight.
Last time I spoke with you, I
got a lot of
flak basically
from people.
And one reason is people
have been accusing you of being
either a fascist or sympathetic.
What people!
To the alt right.
Yeah
And or the far right and
that your project is really about
funneling guns
to these groups that want
to stage some sort of
right-wing coup of the American
government?
Yeah.
Why are you distributing
these guns? What is the purpose of
this?
Well, look, I'll yield this, and
it's in our filings.
For years, our perspective
has always been global.
Our perspective has always been
international and through the
internet. And of course, there's no
level of control on
that that I can affect, that
makes sure that only the right wing
gets access to this equipment.
You know, when we saw the chaz
and some of these street protests of
the left, we saw our patches our
come and take it patches, printed
guns and things like that.
You know, we have no control about
this. If the question is one of,
"Well, what's your personal intent
or why, why are you sympathetic with
the right?" Simply because the right
is the only, the post
political right or whoever you want
to call it, the post left.
You know, these are the only people
actually attempting to quote unquote
resist this
accumulation of centralized power
control
all the methods of what Schmidt
would call deep politicization.
I'm interested in the political.
I'm interested in something beyond
liberal capitalism, and it's just
crushing accumulation
of bureaucratic control and rule by
one mom's lawyer.
And the right wing is the only
incredible artistic esthetic
in America,
the only movement even trying to
think beyond these things and try to
work with new technologies and
techniques.
I saw a
speech that you gave that was posted
on your channel called Post
Politics.
Your goal as a post political
figure is not to give these
people the hallmarks of
a captive mind.
In the speech that Wilson recently
gave at a conference and he posted
on his website and YouTube channel,
he encourages the audience to focus
less on engaging in electoral
politics or debate and persuasion,
and more on maintaining intellectual
independence, political sovereignty
and creating things that constrain
power in the real world.
Your goal is to not to capture.
Is that where you
are thinking of yourself these days
as post political?
And if so, what does that mean,
really?
Look, you could.
You could say that.
I mean, the number one motto on
the internet right now about our
state of politics is that it's
essentially fake and gay.
It's this isn't real.
And not just that it's not
performative, but it's like somehow
cringeworthy and
and connected to a pseudo reality
that's further and further away from
what's actually happening.
And I'll show you this with this
rule. I mean, these people will high
five themselves are like, "Oh, we
solved kid guns and gun crime
in America," right?
And they'll all just like parade
this 100 page solution as some type
of new new era of
peace or something.
But what do they actually do right?
They establish a new, new
coordinates for for the technical
and how we will make guns because of
course, we'll continue to make them.
And they made me some kind of
prophet. Right now, you can only 3D
print and see and email receivers.
Well, God damn, I didn't think I'd
be right.
Literally, five years later, this
is the only way you're going to get
it done privately.
You see, like this is these are two
complete camps. These these people
maybe don't even realize
just how starkly they've diverged
from what's actually happening a
world of people making guns straight
from the internet.
You have to think past the pageantry
of the political, and I don't just
mean TV.
I mean, this idea that our
institutions are somehow
even connected to what's happening.
They they seem to be like the
president himself,
if not dead.
Truly dying.
Zombies. Are they even aware
of what's happening?
The president is a great emblem
of the political, and I just want to
think, man, I just want to live and
imagine what living would
be. And I suppose at this point
that means to notice and to
to think past the political.
So if that is the case
that there's this sort of
institutional zombie
and it offers
up these opportunities,
how would you suggest people
that are in that mindset
act like what should they
do to move forward, you know,
outside the realm of
printing their own 3-D guns?
I think the culture's had time to
adjust to 3D printing guns at this
point. You know, it's a thing you
can do. It's a joke.
It's a punch line.
Same thing with bitcoin.
Everybody's fascinated.
Everybody's involved on some level
or curious.
None of that was true 10 years ago.
People thought this stuff was
science fiction or just like, you
know, somehow a scam
or and I'm not saying that
there aren't scam elements, but
even during COVID in the election of
Biden, this is really helpful.
People are like, "Huh, I can I can
see and sense mainstream people
like they can see and sense that the
president isn't isn't
really the leader of the country.
He's just some kind of ceremonial
installation." And this drives a
deep anxiety, even if it's not
completely conscious.
Pursuing this anxiety and
understanding how to actually do
literally anything to
manufacture something to be in
charge of your own finances, right.
These are deeply post political
activities now.
And so I would, I would simply say,
maintain a firm commitment to what
is actually happening and how that
actually happens.
And don't just get mad at the
ceremonial political figures who
were on TV meant to somehow just
absorb that anger and dissuade
you from investigating what the
actual mechanics of your country and
your time are.
A federal ban on DIY guns may
be a nonstarter in Congress, but
that's not the case at the state and
local level.
Defense Distributed is suing New
Jersey's attorney general in a Texas
court for his attempts to ban the
distribution of gun files and
multiple cities in California have
banned the sale and distribution of
ghost guns.
The state's governor, Gavin Newsom,
has proposed a law modeled on
Texas's new abortion law
that would deputize private citizens
to pursue lawsuits against
individuals who distribute ghost gun
kits.
Do I support Texas's abortion law?
No. I knew it was a bad idea
because it's going to weaponize the
courts even further and push us into
this strange civil war territory.
At the same time, I'm not afraid
of that either.
OK, Newsom is going to say, Well,
you can't sell Ghost Gun kits into
into California.
We'll find what we sell.
We'll never be a Ghost Gun kit, you
understand, but we'll always be
selling something.
We'll always be giving you the ways
to do it. So maybe this knocks out
the low hanging players and what's
left of the so-called Ghost Gun
world. But just as
the Texas law has all these strange
constructions and loopholes, so the
California law will too.
In this forest and this
proliferating forest of competing
laws in ways that allow people to
sue you.
I have the commitment
like the there's the certainty that
it will be somehow easier
to give you the raw materials to
make a firearm.
Where does that commitment or
certainty come from?
There's a world of things that are
not guns.
not gun parts.
We will give you the technology to
turn these things into guns and gun
parts.
Cody Wilson has said personal legal
troubles as well that caused him to
temporarily step back from his role
as Defense Distributed.
In 2018, he was indicted for paying
for sex with a 16 year old girl he
met through a dating site.
Though his legal team at the time
argued he wasn't aware she was
a minor who had lied about her age
to create a profile on the site,
he ended up pleading guilty to a
third degree felony charge, was
sentenced to seven years of
probation and had to register as a
sex offender for that period.
People who are supportive of
the idea you're putting out there
say,"Well, still, you're
not the guy that should be
out there as the face
of this or a spokesman
because of your
legal problems that should forever
make you kind of slink back into
the shadows." What do you say
to that?
I haven't personally seen this
criticism, but you can't choose
your messenger, you know, so I'm
sorry it had to be me.
I was waiting for other people to do
it, and in some respects,
a lot of the movement has risen
up to the challenge. There's a ton
of people doing 3D work right now,
and I don't, you know, I
don't presume to be a spokesperson
for everything happening in
the movement, which I clearly
fathered at the same time.
When we when we have a technical
innovation, I'm going to show the
way I'm not just going to wait for
you to figure it out or to
commercialize it so
you can't choose your messenger.
And maybe in a couple of years,
people change your mind.
Wilson says that a lesson he came
away with from his prior fight with
the federal government is that
politicians and regulators care
most about how they are perceived
and that they will back down quietly
as long as those challenging their
authority are careful not to
publicly embarrass them too much.
The State Department agency,
previously responsible for
regulating those files, gave up its
legal fights, which enabled Wilson
to make the online library of gun
files, DEFCAD, once
again available. Regulation shifted
to a division of the Department of
Commerce, which allows DEFCAD
to host but not generate or sell
the files.
They literally just wrote how we did
DEFCAD into the regulations.
So there's this process of
accommodation happening where power
never admits that it loses,
but it does have to tactically
retreat.
And that is also, I think, why we
have to continue and insisting and
pushing this way, because these
tactical retreats, they show more
and more that power is essentially
impotent in these places.
It knows it.
As long as you don't embarrass it
too much, it will make these
adjustments.
And so I hope then that what we've
done well, I think be another
example of, OK, you know,
try again.